Ladies and gents, welcome to TradeZeller. TradeZeller is the all-in-one
platform that I currently use
to do everything from my back testing to my journaling to all of my processes,
right? My before day
processes, my midday processes, my end-of-day processes. TradeZeller is really
my primary means
of operating. So TradeZeller is my main operating system, or it's the biggest
component of my
operating system. I have another system, a self-built system inside of Notion,
which is more psychological
and kind of behavioral based, but we'll get to that later point. But for
everything trading and
all trading data, TradeZeller is by far the best that's currently on the market
, who knows maybe
I'll be developing my own in the not-so-distant future. But as of right now,
TradeZeller is the
is the go-to. What I'll do is instead of walking you through it just all on my
own, I'm actually
going to guide you to the university section, which does actually a much better
job than I can do in
this episode, and that's what I'll kind of walk you through. So real quick,
obviously I have your
dashboard. I have a account plugged in right now that's an old 200k phase one
and phase two
that I did with Alpha Capital, but this is what the dashboard interface looks
like when
your last kind of trades that were taken were in December. This is what it
looks like, so when
you take a trade, it will come up in your calendar. You'll be able to go into
these, each of these
positions, look at the trades taken, wins, losses, it's going to give you all
of the important data
for your trading. This dashboard interface layout itself, this can be edited. I
have a couple different
ones. I have main data and I have minimalistic data, so you can see main data
is going to give
me more data points that I may want to look at on a week-to-week basis, for
example, but my
minimalist data dashboard is what I focus on on a day-to-day. You have your
daily journal,
you're all of the trades you've taken, your notebook for all of the notes that
you've taken,
your reports, this is actually a really, really valuable feature. I'll give you
a quick brief overview.
All of your KPIs are pretty much in here, your average daily P&L, your average
winning day,
your average losing day. What do I make on an average winning day? What do I
make on an average
losing day? My largest profitable day, my largest losing day, right? All of
these KPIs,
and this is where the biggest part of your growth comes in, is because you look
at all your data,
you organize it all, and it's organized pretty well here, and then the key is
looking at one to two
things that you want to improve on, and then building a hypothesis on how you
're going to improve that.
So you find the biggest part on X, maybe your average losing trade is larger
than your average
winning trade, for example. You may be still profitable, but if that's the case
, then that's a big red flag,
and so you can look at that piece of data and be like, "Okay, let's dive deeper
into it." That's
definitely one KPI that I'm going to look to increase. Now you're going to look
at all the
ways. Am I risking too much on losing trades? Am I taking profits too early?
All of these different
things that could be the deep-rooted issue. Then you go into that, and then you
dissect it even
deeper. You just go layers and layers and layers until you finally identify the
one to three core
problems that is the cause of your low score of your KPI, and then you work on
a plan to increase
it, and then you track that plan. It becomes a hypothesis. You're literally
like a data scientist
at that point. All of these things are things that will go into a lot more
detail later. You have
your playbooks, you have your progress tracker, you have your trade replay, you
have your resource
center. These are all the features on the tracking. Then you have your back
testing, you have your
mental mode, which is something we'll talk about at a later date. Then you have
university. Instead
of going through all the features myself, I'll just go through the university
because inside of this
university, it pretty much gives you everything you need to know on how to use
trade seller,
and there's so much value in here that really just makes you an incredible,
incredible trader.
I've been using trade seller for a while now, and even I took so much value
from this university
section to get this level of value from just a back testing and journal.
Software is ridiculous.
The university alone is more valuable than the price you're paying your
subscription. That's
hands down. There is not a single trader who's watching this video that shouldn
't have trade
seller, and because you're a member of our community, you also get either your
first month free,
if there's space available for that, or you'll anyway get at least a discount
just by using a
select 20% or something. It's literally a no-brainer. If you're serious about
becoming a profitable trader
and you don't have trade seller, then you're obviously not serious because it
has everything.
So what I would like to do is I'll kind of walk you through the most valuable
areas of the university. How to take control of your mind? It's okay, but there
's a lot of fluff
in this. This doesn't even come close to the inner edge. So there's some good
detail on it.
You can watch it, sorry, but yeah. This here is impeccable. So how to analyze
your data like a pro.
So understanding your key metrics, collecting, organizing your data. This here,
which you shouldn't
have to worry about, but you still watch it. Anyway, how to properly analyze
trade expectancy.
Understand that in utilizing trading KPIs, this is extremely valuable. These
three videos are
extremely valuable. Successful playbooks. Build your trading playbook. This was
really valuable,
but breaking down when Umar comes in and kind of breaks down some of his play
books, I'll be real.
I don't think he's given everything in his playbooks. Just going to be fully
transparent.
This building a trading playbook is super cool. Stopped for option traders, not
important,
how to scale up correctly, not important, not too important, how to analyze
your position size data.
It all can be valuable, risk management. Again, a lot of this is surface level
and a lot of just
chatter with risk management. You're not going to get much more from this risk
management than
you would have gotten just a basic couple of episodes that we went through, but
you can still
go for it. This is super valuable. This entire area, honestly, is really
valuable. Trade recap,
workflow, journaling, your trades, importance of game plans and recaps. This
area, this how to
journal your trades like a pro area is super valuable. How to manage risk like
a pro is decent.
This one building your playbook is decent. How to analyze your data like a pro
is decent,
how to take control of your mind. For me personally, I didn't get that much
value from it.
How to back test like a pro. I guess it's valuable. I haven't watched this one.
Haven't watched
this one. I watched the 2.0 launch. I want to understand the features of it.
Traded development webinar. This wasn't the most valuable to me personally, but
it all depends
where you are as well, like in your journey. Q&A is I didn't go for any of them
. I'm not really
interested in the Q&A. It's probably some value in there for you guys. I had to
review a trade like
a pro that was valuable. And then this is just obviously getting started. This
is just what you
really need. So you watch these and it's going to break down the entire
platform. It makes it
really simple. That's what I would look at. Part-time to full-time trading.
That's pretty cool.
I haven't watched it, but sounds pretty cool. I guess these are new. Struct
uring your day for
success. Also pretty cool. Introduction to order flow. I would leave that for
now. Anything that's
just kind of overwhelm you. I'll be totally honest with you. I would more be
focused on how to use
the platform and then features like how to be better at using the platform,
like how to journal
like a pro. And I can recreate all of these episodes for you, but I just don't
have to do the point if
you can just grab them from Zella's University. So honestly, what Umar's built
hands down, like
very, very impressed. Huge advocate for this, for the value that it produces. I
would love to
build my own at some point. That's the goal. Highly recommend it. Like non-neg
otiable if I'm
going to be totally honest with you. There is nothing in it for me. Like I'm
going to give you a 20%
discount. I'm going to make like 10% in affiliate commissions for transparen
cies. Like I asked them
give as much of a discount with as little possible commission to me, but the
important part is
getting you guys the discount and getting you on here. More importantly, like
it's, it's non-negotiable.
I'm just going to give you the best chance of becoming consistently profitable.
So highly, highly, highly, highly recommend it. There's so many features that I
could walk you
through, but you'll go through it all and probably better going through it in
university instead of
me walking you through it, because I can waffle a lot. These modules are just
straight to the
point on how to use it. If you have any questions, do feel free to put them in
the community. I
understand this platform pretty much inside and out. So yeah, if you do have
any questions,
don't hesitate. But if you're watching this, you should be on TradeZilla if you
aren't already,
obviously, or maybe using an FX replay or something, which I used to use for
backtesting.
But soon as TradeZilla released their backtesting, although at the beginning,
it wasn't as comprehensive
as FX replay. I had both of the subscriptions running, but I would say now they
're at a point where
they're on par with FX replay. If not better, it has some better functionality,
like the reporting
system, but I know FX replay are also working on a lot of updates as well. So
competition is always
good, right? Competition is always good for innovation. It's always good for
the end consumer.
But yeah, that is pretty much TradeZilla. I implore you to go take a look. I
will leave links
down in the description of either a free month or a discount. Even if you get
the free month,
you can still apply the discount after. They don't do any free trials. They don
't do anything
like that. But what they have done for our community specifically and what I've
got for you guys
is them to give, I think it's 100 accounts a month that has access to a free
account.
Information to that will be down in the description of this if they are still.
But yeah, guys,
That's Trey Zeller. Get on there and if you have any questions, don't hesitate
to let me know.